in this video we're going to take a
deeper look at the various producers and
consumers in an ecosystem and for the
sake of diversity no pun intended we're
going to look at a marine ecosystem
let's say an estuary and an estuary
generally refers to a place where you
have a river coming to where the tide
comes so it's a mixture of both the
fresh water from the river and the salt
water from the sea and they tend to be
very productive from an energetic or a
biomass point of view so if i were to
make an energy pyramid for let's say
this estuary that we're looking at right
over here it might look something like
this
where at the bottom layer these are the
primary producers and we've studied this
in other videos
primary producers
in a marine environment these would be
things like phytoplankton phyto they're
doing photosynthesis and they're
plankton plankton is a general term it
comes from the greek for drifter this
right over here is sea grass
also something that can photosynthesize
and this right over here is algae which
i'm sure you have seen when you've gone
to the sea or you've gone to a pond of
some sort
and when we think of photosynthesis we
often talk about terrestrial things
things like trees but a lot of us don't
realize that 50 percent
that's a big number of earth's
photosynthesis or
net primary production or organic energy
compounds is produced by floating
photosynthesizers like phytoplankton and
ultraplankton so things like this things
that you oftentimes don't see and as i
mentioned estuaries tend to be quite
productive they actually are comparable
to things like rainforests now for the
sake of making things tangible this
being an estuary which is very
productive let's imagine that the net
primary production from this first layer
we could think about it in terms of
biomass maybe it's about 2 000
grams
per
square meter
per year or we could think about it in
terms of calories this would be
approximately equal to it depends on the
type of biomass you're talking about but
you have roughly four kilocalories per
gram so that would be roughly 8 000
kilocalories
per
square meter per year that's the net
primary production of this first layer
of the primary producers
then what would we see at the next layer
well we know that not all of that energy
can be used by that next layer which
would be the primary consumers
and there are some examples here it's
much more
complex than what this pyramid depicts
but what we see here these are
zooplankton which are really you could
view it as animal plankton it's a large
category of things they have the word
plankton in it so they kind of have to
go with the flow of whatever the tide is
doing whatever the currents are doing
another primary consumer could be a fish
like this royal blue tang that might be
eating plankton
and the net energy that's available to
the layer above that is going to be a
small fraction of the net primary
productivity of that first layer
typically it's about 10 percent so there
might be instead of 8 000 kilocalories
10 percent of that we'd be talking about
approximately 800
potential kilocalories per square meter
per year that would be available for the
next layer
now you might be saying hey
where is all where are all the other
calories going well remember even in
this first layer we said this is net
primary production the growth would be
even higher these photosynthesizers
had to use that energy for things like
respiration and even on the net basis
the reason why so much gets lost when
you go to the next layer is these
animals here they have to use that
energy to live to do things like
respiration and a lot of this energy is
just not consumable by the next layer so
it can become detritus which is you can
just think of this biomass that is just
laying around energy at every level can
be lost to heat can be used for movement
for growth so you can imagine you get to
a level above that we could call this
secondary
consumer
and this is just a picture of a grouper
marine ecosystems would be much more
complex than this but the net calories
after the groupers live their life etc
etc that is available to the level above
that would be roughly again 10 so maybe
80
kilocalories
per square meter per year and then at
least in this example at the top of this
pyramid we have an apex predator that is
a shark
what is available
after the shark's done all of its
business is roughly 10 of that so
approximately eight kilocalories
per square meter
per
year
and so the important thing to think
about is
whether we're talking about terrestrial
or marine environments you have this
significant loss of energy as we go from
one layer of the pyramid to another but
at the same time everyone has to be
using energy and the energy has to come
from some place and we've covered in
other videos it's coming from sunlight
and there has to be this continual
process of taking light energy and
through photosynthesis converting it
into a form of energy that can be used
by life and then you have significant
energy loss but that energy keeps
flowing up this pyramid and we're not
even done because even the apex
predators at some point they're going to
die and then they have tissue and in
that biomass there's energy that could
be consumed by others to also to release
nutrients that could be used by these
initial primary producers and that's
where things like detrivores and this is
a starfish which is a detrivore things
that can actually consume dead matter
they are really useful because then they
can bring nutrients back to primary
producers and to others and when we're
talking about an aquatic environment
like this and we're talking about
photosynthesis one question you might be
asking is wait well where can photosys
synthesis occur if you go deep enough
it's going to get quite dark and you'd
be right if you were asking that
question when you think about marine
environments there's something known as
a euphodic zone
which is the zone where it's shallow
enough to get enough light so that you
can actually do photosynthesis and so
it's no coincidence that things like
estuaries things where the water is
shallower where there's going to be more
nutrients and there's going to be more
light that you actually have more
primary production